quel est le plus gros cliché auquel tu
dois faire face en tant que jeune ni
même
un jeune ne peut pas être religieux on
ne peut pas aimer la religion pourquoi
parce que je pense que les gens ont en
tête un peu l'image du jeûne qui aime la
vie et qui ont dit profite de ta vie
mais je profite de ma vie au fait les
religieusement
[Musique]
vous n'avez jamais mis d'alcool je n'ai
jamais bu d'alcool pourtant je sais
qu'il y a des versets sur le vin
absolument
festif non en fait vous savez les les
comment dire la législation a été
descendue par étape vous voyez et on
retrouve ces étapes parfois sur un
certain nombre de questions dans le
Coran donc effectivement ça n'a pas été
interdit tout de suite d'abord on a dit
aux Compagnons du Prophète de s'en
éloigner il y a dedans effectivement des
choses qui sont bien mais aussi des
choses qui sont mauvaises et puis
ensuite de vos approchez pas de la
prière lorsque vous êtes ivre et puis
ensuite on interdit purement et
simplement c'est pour ça qu'on dit
toujours oui mais pour appliquer sa
religion on va pas juste voir dans le
Coran conclusion qui nous disent c'est
pas écrit dans le Coran oui mais au fait
il y a le Coran et puis il y a d'autres
sources aussi
il y a les récits prophétiques il y a le
consensus des savants et puis il y a
l'adolégie et puis il y en a des
dizaines d'autres
alors le halal au fait en arabe ça veut
dire juste licite au fait autorisé rien
d'autre que cela quand on parle de
viande halal on parle au fait de la
viande qui est donc ici pour le musulman
et pour la musulmane au fait qui a été
sacrifié selon un rythme particulier
religieusement on a 5 jugements et donc
une chose tout ce que je fais dans ma
vie au fait dans ma journée à forcement
un de ces cinq statuts là religieusement
soit c'est haram interdit soit c'est
déconseillé détestable macro soit c'est
autorisé donc halal ou mouba soit c'est
conseillé ou bien ça peut être
obligatoire pourquoi tu as le droit de
manger toutes les viandes sauf le porc
parce que aujourd'hui dans les mosquées
il y a un tapis et que si on marche avec
nos chaussures sur le tapis on l'abîme
et aussi on risque de mettre de mettre
des impuretés en fait à l'endroit où en
prix et la prière n'est pas valide si
j'ai je porte sur moi une impureté que
je sais que j'ai sûrement une impureté
ou que je suis sur une impureté donc on
évite cela vous avez le
droit c'est pas ça du coup c'est pas
mais c'est pas interdit mais au fait
l'objectif peut déterminer au fait le
jugement de la chose donc l'objectif là
c'est de rencontrer des personnes
en dehors du cadre de mariage donc
effectivement c'est pas une chose qui
autorise et par contre rencontrer une
personne pour faire connaissance dans le
cadre enfin dans l'objectif de se marier
là effectivement oui ce serait autorisé
est-ce que tu as des amis non
j'ai des amis non croyants alors
maintenant mon activité du coup me prend
pas mal de temps et du coup forcément je
l'ai enfin on est un peu moins en lien
mais j'ai des connaissances en croyant
bien sûr et ça donne lieu à des débats
oui forcément d'autant plus aujourd'hui
avec les débats qui courent dans les
médias oui ça donne lieu à des débats
effectivement comme quoi comme pourquoi
est-ce que vous faites toujours une
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes pourquoi est-ce que vous ne
mangez pas de porc à quoi ça sert le
ramadan des questions un petit peu
basiques et puis parfois des questions
qui sont un peu plus poussées qui
demandent la réflexion genre pourquoi tu
crois en Dieu comment on devient imam
alors il y a pas au fait à la base de
cursus vraiment dédié religieusement
pour devenir imam au fait ce sont les
personnes qui ont atteint un degré
vraiment haut dans les sciences
religieuses et qui ont les capacités
d'être aimables et bien les gens leur
demandent d'être immeubles très
simplement maintenant effectivement
aujourd'hui la
l'organisation des choses fait que il
est nécessaire d'avoir un petit peu des
cursus qui soient dédiés donc il existe
aujourd'hui des cursus de formation
d'imams
moi j'ai subi un cursus de formation
donc pour les immeubles au Maroc que
j'ai complété avec des cours un peu
traditionnels c'est l'équivalent d'un
bac + quoi + 5 absolument bac + 5
comment un imam gagne sa vie alors il y
a pas de où je schéma au fait uniforme
comment un immeuble gagne sa vie dans
beaucoup de mosquées au fait ce sont les
dons des fidèles effectivement qui
contribuent à un petit peu
rétribué l'imam et puis parfois il y a
des mosquées qui ont un peu plus de
moyens parce qu'ils ont des relations
avec l'extérieur très simplement
1500 jusque
je sais pas 3000 mais vraiment fils à la
louche comme ça c'est
quoi le plus la considération
considération
quand les gens en fait il l'image qu'on
les gens un petit peu du rôle difficile
vis-à-vis peut-être si on parle des avis
des gens mais au fait l'imam il a la
conscience tranquille il sait ce qu'il
fait il sait pourquoi il le fait et il
le fait d'avoir forcé mais effectivement
le regard parfois des personnes les dire
des uns et des autres rendent pas au
fait la tâche facile tous les jours